[موسيقى]
اخطبوط برتبه عراف قط متنبا وماعز منجم
حيوانات حازت شهره واسعه الاف من المشجعين
تسمروا امامها وامام الشاشات بانتظار
اعلانها توقعات نتيجه احدى المباريات
المرتقبه في كاس العالم
الاخطبوط بول يكاد يكون اكثر هذه
الحيوانات شهره لتحقق معظم توقعاته خصوصا
في مباريات يكون المنتخب الالماني طرفا
فيها
بول توقع نتيجه اثنتي عشره مباراه من ضمن
14 بشكل صحيح
وبلغت نسبه ذقته نحو سته و80%
حياته هذا الحيوان لم تستمر سوى عامين
ونصف العام
لكنه خلال هذه الفتره الوجيزه حاضيه
باهتمام اعلامي دولي كبير
تحديدا عندما توقع فوز اسبانيا بمونديال
2010 خبر وفاه الاخطبوط لم يكن خبرا عاديه
وهو سائل الاعلام والمحبون توافدوا على
منزله الزجاج في مركز للحياه البحريه
بالمانيا لتوديعه
يعني اتحولت ثاني قديم
من القطط نجمه بزغ في مونديال 2018 بعد ما
تنبا بدقه بنتائج اربع مباريات خلال
البطوله
همم
هؤلاء المصورين
ممثلا او لاعب مشهور لكن لالتقاط صوره
للقط اخيل حيث يقيم في متحف ارميتاج في
مدينه سام بطرسبرج الروسي روسيه قصه تنبؤ
الحيوانات بنتائج مباريات كاس العالم لم
تقف عند بول واخيل حيوان السرقات ايضا لا
هو نصيب من مهمه التنجيم فهنا في احدى
حدائق الحيوان الروسيه يعيش تيمون وينتظر
الاشاره
ليفصح عن توقعاته
طريقه تيمون
ويعيش في فرنسا ولديه ايضا موهبه التوقع
وهذه دلافين متنبه تقوم بالمهمه نفسها
وهذه ايضا ليست مجرد ماعز اسمها زابياكا
فهي عرافه محترفه بلغت دقه تنبؤاتها نحو
سته 66 بالمئه
هذه السلسله الطويله من الحيوانات
المتنبيه لا تنتهي البعض يؤمن فعلا بما
تتنبا به واخرون يعتبرون توقعاتها من قبيل
الصدفه فقط
فماذا عنكم هل تصدقون هذه التنبؤات
[موسيقى]